[Music]
Robert Spencer here for jihad watch a
program of the David Horowitz Freedom
Center and for the Center for Security
Policy today I've got a Man Bites Dog
story for you w k BW reported recently
that a Muslim in Lackawanna New York
named Arafat Nagi pleaded guilty in
federal court to a charge of attempting
to provide material support and
resources to a foreign terrorist
organization in his plea Nagi admitted
he had tried to support ISIL that is the
Islamic state by personally traveling to
Turkey in an effort to enter Syria and
fight on behalf of Isis and the big news
was that a Muslim ratted him out
officials handling his case stated on
our August 28 2014 a community member
told the FBI that Nagi talked about
violent jihad to many people in the
Lackawanna community and it was common
for naggy to get into verbal complaints
over his jihad beliefs in a similar vein
the Buffalo News informs us that the
case against Arafat M Nagi began more
than three years ago fueled by a tip
from a community member AB set about
Nagas vocal support for violent jihad so
is the Muslim community in Lackawanna
New York moderate patriotic and
determined to cooperate with law
enforcement officials to route all the
jihadis and jihad sympathizers out of
its ranks
unfortunately that cannot be concluded
from the case of Arafat Nagi this was a
man who made his determination to commit
jihad violence so obvious that Muslim
community members had no choice but to
act w KBW says the FBI's further
investigation uncovered Nagi pledged
allegiance to Isis and group leader Abu
Bakr al-baghdadi investigators say he
traveled to Turkey twice in October 2012
and July 2014 with the intent to meet
Isis members before traveling to Turkey
he bought a large number of military
combat items including a tactical vest
Army Combat shirt body armor Shahadah
flag combat boots backpack bird
kit hunting knife machete and
night-vision goggles once in Turkey
he bought a SIM card activated a Turkish
cell phone number and Facebook messaged
other people who were prepared to help
Nagi enter Syria to join nice Isis it
gets worse w k BW adds the FBI raided
his Lackawanna home back in 2015 the
investigation into nabis alleged
involvement with ISIL was long and
methodical and lasted several months it
began when the FBI says a grand jury
subpoena connected a yahoo email account
to the Lackawanna address Nagi returned
to the US and September after being
overseas for two months and the FBI says
his phone number was the same as the
phone number used for the yahoo account
we're still aside from all his jihad
plotting and activity now he was in
accord with the qur'an's command to beat
disobedient women violent toward his
daughter wkb w reports Lackawanna police
arrested Nagi in July 2013 on charges he
threatened to kill his daughter police
say a witness was with Nagi's daughter
when he pulled up next to them and
displayed a large knife not his daughter
ran inside her home and called 911 s
told police Nagi stated he was going to
shoot and behead his daughter now he was
charged but it's unclear what became of
those charges
well what indeed did become of them we
hear a great deal about how the Muslim
community in the u.s. rejects an a pores
jihad violence and yet the Hamas linked
Council on american-islamic relations
care the most influential Muslim group
in the u.s. routinely distributes flyers
telling Muslims not to cooperate with
law enforcement only rarely do we hear
about Muslims informing law enforcement
about jihadi such as Arafat Nagi and now
he was making his jihad sentiments so
blazingly obvious that he forced their
hand if they hadn't informed on him it
would have cast suspicion on a larger
segment of the community since he was
apparently telling anyone who would
listen to him about how he was going to
wage jihad against the infidels oh and
why wasn't he under constant or at least
regular surveillance after threatening
to kill his daughter how is he able to
amass all that jihad equipment without
any suspicion isn't any of that a matter
of concern to law enforcement if law
enforcement officials had been allowed
to study Islam as the motivating
ideology of jihad terrorism they might
have surmised that his willingness to
behead his own daughter was a
manifestation of an adherence to Islam
that could also suggest involvement in
Jihad activity in that case they might
have caught him much sooner
even without the community's
whistleblowing but of course to draw
such conclusions would have been
Islamophobic and so it goes in our
republic of willful ignorance I am
Robert Spencer
[Music]